Casey what do you IV get out take it
hey I'm Greg yeah we go over there okay
great all right
oh we are recording have we really yeah
oh God hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and this is Casey spit vive IV hey this
is Casey Spivey right here
yes and I've seen her from Screen Rant
and she is this actual hilarious
comedian slash actress wonderful host
the Screen Rant
I followed her on Instagram and then
suddenly I bump into her at a bar and
she ends up being a really kind human
being not a fake person so now she's on
the real rejects YouTube channel with me
this is the most monumental thing you
could have ever done in your entire
career to be honest right it is really
we are way more popular than screen you
can follow Casey at hey underscore Casey
Kate Scott hey underscore case on
Instagram it's quitter it's not just
provocative photos it's actual fun
content over there
she actually works to get a following
well today we're gonna watch the Murder
on the Orient Express trailer number two
have you seen the first trailer yes
you know that song just go so well with
this
[Laughter]
[Music]
still this off
[Music]
[Music]
the Johnny Depp he was
[Music]
you are so kind it was in
you think of it
[Music]
right here
I can see everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
I think Casey Spivey has a issue would J
Depp
I just I'm just over it I'm over his
same character every single time that's
not the same he sounds a little more
like himself
yeah Johnny so Charles for me to talk on
a weird yeah I've got the scar dhalsim
I'm different character you know what I
appreciated about that trailer I know
the first trailer got a lot of crap for
using that believer song really I
imagine right yeah because everyone's
like this doesn't fit it just doesn't
make sense a shape [ __ ] you're trying to
be edgy and appeal to the Millennials
yeah like that's what it felt like like
yeah they did this like remix of it kind
of like yeah like softer instruments
like yeah I was like huh you guys had
too big of an ego to let the song go ha
so you made a different version that if
it's better actually yeah good on you
guys good on you guys right there now
the movie looks fun to me people are
excited about it
I don't really something tells me it's
just gonna be okay though I liked the
first trailer better there's a little
bit more of a tone mystery to it I feel
like they're trying to gang up along yes
very it seems like the movie was gonna
be stylized in the first trailer I don't
get that I get that this is oh it's just
a regular movie I don't know I mean the
way stuff is framed and how the way the
camera moved through the Train and the
last one I was like oh maybe this is
like yeah unique take on the story and
like oh no it's just the story it does
sort of feel like that I'll give I'll
give you that I mean because I'm where
the first trailer had that one long
tracking shot of the entire people the
people who were gonna be a part of the
suspicion game yeah and yeah that was me
I feel like this movie would probably be
miss marketed honestly because it's not
a terrible trailer I feel like they're
trying to make it seem like this
different kind of exciting vibe than
what the actual vibe might
b-because you got a bunch of great
character actors in here including
Johnny it's weird because there's a lot
of color and a lot of light and it's
almost like I would rather it be like
Girl with the Dragon Tattoo girl on the
train I had a good murder mystery I said
it feels like a pg-13 Hollywood driven
yeah yeah I go you're saying I wonder if
the film will actually play out that way
because this feels like it could be
darker than what we're actually getting
I hope it's dark I want this to be dark
well it should be
it's called Murder on the Orient Express
yeah I haven't read the book I haven't
read a page I can't remember the
author's name Agatha Christie yes oh so
smart
who needs to read the book now I feel
like this shows being miss Margot in
terms of its style and tone because you
know you get great shots with these
actors doing some intense stuff right
you got Michelle Pfeiffer who as you see
mother I didn't yet oh you would love it
easiest movie going experience yeah grab
your popcorn and soda pop and I
guarantee wow this is really funny the
funny movie it's it's solid kind of bold
comedy yeah family comedy it really is
about family and love at the end of the
day well yeah I mean you got a bunch of
these great actors in there Michelle
Pfeiffer I'm glad to see her back like
working consistently Johnny Depp's not
in the last trailer I know he's he can
kind of get on peoples nerves now
because he plays the same character a
lot Oh was he got in the last trailer he
was briefly in it okay but in that long
tracking shot he's not feature of it
that's what I cuz I was like why is he
in it what yeah I thought he was the one
he was killed because of the last
trailer and now I'm seeing him I think
it was because he had a whole Amber
Heard thing go down oh so they were like
yeah yeah where amber her beat him I
shouldn't make that joke a lot of people
I mean the movie right now it looks okay
to me I'm probably gonna end up watching
it cuz I don't think there's any other
big movie with a bunch of actors coming
out November 10th oh this is coming out
soon yeah it's a holiday film this is a
holiday film and that's that's probably
what the point you're getting at though
earlier is like this shouldn't be a Holi
the holiday movie because be a holic
holiday cuz you were saying this could
be like a girl with a dragon tattoo yeah
girl the dragon tattoos didn't do so
well that came out on Christmas you know
it didn't do so long Christmas there
were other movies families wanted to
watch that I feel like this movie could
they're probably like well we can't go
to raw with this trailer right now well
maybe it's just a fun thriller who knows
I'm kind of like lukewarm all this looks
very like Titanic to me I just want to
frame the look the look of the thing the
whole thing it's like very like Rome's
boat together in candlelight when really
it should be like we're stuck on a train
together and there's a murder murder
yeah it's great I just have a different
vibe yeah yeah we like footage are you
guys excited for Murder on the Orient
Express is this the most cool thing
you've seen in a while you're all
excited today subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell you
can follow three regex patreon and
become a picture on objective day but
beyond all those things none of them
really matter what really matters is if
you go follow Casey's fiber didn't even
need it really under the impression
names fiber no don't it's okay Casey's
hey case a underscore case a tu i
underscore ka ze on Instagram Twitter
and catch her on screen rant where she
does actual videos on screen rant video
complete